I've already been in 30 states I got
another three or four more to go before
we reach New Year's they do know how mad
we are do you know how how this ugliness
is damned desire to be heard not to
listen to learn but to be heard how it's
undermining so many things and it
doesn't have to be this way
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special today we are
joined by dr. Frank Luntz Frank is the
pioneer of the instant response focus
group technique and the New York Times
bestselling author of words that work
he's best known for his political
commentary with more media outlets
turning to him to understand American
voters than any other political pollster
Frank thanks so much for taking the time
to stop I really appreciate it suppose
it's only what 50 minutes from my house
so it's actually pretty close
you're a convenient guess and it made
perfect sense so why don't we start with
what's on everybody's mind how do you
assess trump's president Trump's
standing leading up to the 20/20
election does he still have controlled
the IRS can i still be audited on a
accomplishment level when he's actually
done is incredibly impressive the
unemployment rate at a 50-year low black
unemployment and an all-time low Latino
unemployment at an all-time low wages
going up the economy strong even with
all the yelling over China economically
it's been pretty incredible tax policy
people get to keep more of their
hard-earned income in foreign policy
we're not in the middle of a war on what
he's done it's pretty impressive and how
he says it how he communicates I'm not
sure how much of it I like he and I have
talked infrequently but enough and I've
expressed some concern and I'll give you
an example he likes to talk about
building the wall which I'm sure that
most of your viewers appreciate the
problem is when you're talking about
building a wall you've got 40 percent
support sixty percent opposition if you
talk about building a barrier it goes up
to 60 percent if you talk about using
human intelligence technology a physical
barrier where it's necessary if you're
precise about it it goes up to 79
percent support Trump's idea of
instilling border security it's a winner
the public supports the Democrats
supported but when you just talk about a
wall it's a great applause line for his
supporters but it doesn't get you
where you need to go and on issues like
this sometimes what he says actually
undermines what he wants to do so a lot
of his supporters will say well the
world of politics has changed she
understands that we live in the base
only world that the moderates don't
exist anymore there aren't any swing
voters it's just a matter of getting
your base excited and also they might
say something like well if Trump says
build a barrier then the next thing that
happens the media event just spin on
that language and suddenly barriers are
bad because no matter what Trump does
the media will always caricature as as
the greatest of all evils so you
obviously spent your career picking the
words that work trying to help people
figure out what's the best way to
express themselves to be convincing does
that matter in an era of Trump have
things changed fundamentally or are we
just you're correct they have
fundamentally changed and I have to
admit I had an argument with the
president over stuff that he said about
Baltimore which is a very troubled City
I know something of it because I used to
go to sporting events there and on
occasion I would travel into the
community and it is not a healthy City
but it should not be derided that way I
just I have I felt very bad for the
people because I thought they were being
insulted because one of their
congressman was challenging Trump
directly and what I got back from his
campaign manager is that I'm elitist I
come from the old-fashioned
establishment I don't understand that
under Donald Trump we call things what
they are and my parents taught me at a
very young age and I should know because
I'm overweight today but you don't walk
up to a fat person and say hey you
realize you're fat you don't say
everything that comes to your mind you
don't insult people when you don't need
to and if you disagree with them you
find a way to bring them over rather
than trying to bludgeon them and so his
communication for me and I've said this
to him is very problematic but I won't
let that get in the way of what he's
accomplished and I won't let what he's
accomplished get in the way of how he
communicates that they are both
important America is a great country
because we're a good country it is not
that we have a wonderful GPA at GPA
wonderful GNP it is not that we are
she's my head is in in academia it's not
that we are wealthy it's that when
people are hurting Americans come when
people are suffering were the ones who
do something about it we're always the
first and we don't ask for a thank you
we just do it because it's who we are
and what we're about and I want us to be
good people not just as successful
people and I wish that some of the
language were a little bit more gentle I
think he can still really energize his
base I think he can be just as
successful if he tones to stuff down a
bit and I know that he doesn't agree I
know that the campaign people don't
agree we'll just have to agree to
disagree
yeah I mean one of the things I have
suggested to members of his campaign is
that it's for me it's not even
necessarily the language used although I
have many of the same problems it's the
targets of the language that he uses
meaning that if you want to speak
bluntly about you know Abu Bakar all
Baghdady whining and whimpering in a
cave I don't think that many Americans
have a problem with that I think if you
apply similar language to make a
Brzezinski then suddenly a lot of
suburban women go I'm no not not super
interested in that I do wonder if the
the because the art of politics is the
art of persuasion and Trump is not a
persuader he's just a blunt instrument
who says whatever comes to mind and that
way he thinks he is he thinks he is he
thinks he turns people around and
arguably we've never had a candidate who
had a forty-percent john approval rating
38% on election day and got elected
president so it's clearly something he's
saying is tapping into a strong near
majority of the population it's not a
majority and so he thinks that because
he went from 38% approval in 2016 and
he's at 43% now he's gonna do even
better in the election and what I've
tried to communicate is you're losing
people who would vote for you otherwise
but they just don't like what you say
and they feel so uncomfortable about it
and they don't want to go through four
more years of this anger and yelling and
and everything being a crisis or
everything being in chaos and again I
know your viewers the first thing
they're doing right now we're only six
minutes into the show they're typing
away that I'm a traitor or I'm a rhino
or I don't get it but the thing is I do
because unlike most of your viewers I'm
in virtually every state in the country
every year
I've already been in 30 states I got
another three or four more to go before
we reach New Year's not many people talk
to as many people as I do they do know
how mad we are I do know how how this
ugliness is this damn desire to be heard
not to listen not to learn but to be
heard how it's undermining so many
things and it doesn't have to be this
way so in a second I want to ask you
about since you've been in all these
states where you think the swing states
are going because the polls have been
actually fairly strong for Trump in the
swing states even though nationally he's
pulling very poorly so I'm ask you about
that in just one second but first let's
talk about the importance of protecting
your data it is very important to
protect our data because lots of people
are after it big tech hackers the
government I've been talking about
expressvpn on my show for so long you
already understand why encrypting your
network data is important but some of
you have still not acted so why why well
maybe you're thinking it doesn't affect
you because hey you're not me and lots
of people are my dear but they don't
want your data wrong way to think about
this if you don't use Express VPN that's
like leaving your front door unlocked
every time you go out sure nothing might
happen for years when a break-in does
happen they're gonna take your
silverware one of the easiest ways to
secure your internet data expressvpn you
click one button on your computer or
your smartphone and now you are
protected this is why I use Express VPN
people want my data hackers woman I've
been hacked before it is no fun I've had
people attempt to hack into not only my
personal data but also into my credit
cards it's terrible the only question is
why haven't you gotten expressvpn yet I
did
now I'm protected visit my special link
right now expressvpn comm slash man get
an extra three months of expressvpn for
free it's a great deal protect your
internet today with the VPN I trust to
keep my data safe go to expressvpn comm
slash Ben to get started okay so let's
talk for a second about the the swing
states so you just talked about how many
states you've been in and obviously for
a president from this election basically
comes down to the swing states his
chances of
the national popular vote continued to
be extremely low California in New York
are just too populous he is pulling well
from the polls that I've seen in
Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania more
durably than I thought he would at this
point not Pennsylvania but yes in
Michigan and yes in Wisconsin but there
are other states you have to look at
Ohio because sherrod Brown could be a
vice presidential nominee with any
Democrat and that means for high OH
switches you have to look at Iowa
because of the trade war and the farmers
being particularly hurt and Trump's
unfavorability has been rising over the
last three or four months in that state
obviously look at North Carolina I
consider that state to be the most
evenly divided of any in the country
then to others New Hampshire and Arizona
on the Republican side and frankly
there's a chance that Republicans could
win Minnesota from the Democrats so
those are the states and I'm following
you'll notice I didn't say Florida I
actually think Trump will do okay there
but these states are too close to call
the Democrats know just as much as the
Republicans do and in those states we're
gonna have three billion dollars spent
on eight or nine states and there's only
six percent of the population that is
truly undecided so imagine spending
three billion dollars on 20% of the
states and six percent of the people in
this way we should just buy them a car
but that's that's what it's gonna feel
like it's gonna be $1,000 per voter to
try to influence them so how much does
the Democratic nominee matter so
president from specialty may not be
building up his own likability as what
I've said is that politics is the art of
making it difficult to vote for your
opponent and easy to vote for you and
Trump is great at one part of that and
horrible at the other which again he
doesn't understand is he'll be watching
this and say oh that's ridiculous he
knows nothing but he doesn't hear and he
says he does but I don't believe he does
because he would feel the people who
have a job now who didn't who have more
money in their pockets than they did
three years ago that key question are
you better off today than you were four
years ago he's succeeding in that he
really is and he's getting no credit
from the media you would not know that
from the network she would not know that
from the
news programs but even though they're
better off they're still hesitant and he
asked to ask himself why with an economy
that's the strongest economy in my
lifetime I know in yours
surely in mine too why isn't he at 55%
approval
why isn't he beating every Democrat by
15 to 20% if he were Barack Obama at
this point it would be a landslide
it's not and I recognize that the media
does not give him a fair shake but even
part of that as his fault
beating up on them really killing them
at press conferences ridiculing the
whole profession everyone uses the
phrase fake news I've been in a dozen
countries in the last six months and
they are talking about fake news and
every time I hear this I think wow the
president really has had a global
interest he should understand that it
doesn't have to be this way but he
doesn't which makes Joe Biden a 50/50
shot for president it makes a Elizabeth
Warren who I think is the next most
likely nominee makes her a 45 percent
shot even though her positions are
extreme any of these Democrats any of
them have a shot not because of what
Trump has done but because of what he
has said let's go through some of the
Democratic field so I agree that the
Biden I've been saying this you know for
years the Biden is the strongest
candidate to go up against Trump mainly
because it's not bad to be a natural
corpse running against Trump meaning if
you're just a default not a live human
being then you're probably gonna perform
better against Trump than somebody who
doesn't have it all baked into the cake
now you'd realize if you only said it a
little bit slower he could actually hear
you there's only so much I can do with
that I lose my train of thought and also
I like to exist just on the edge of a
speed where only dogs can hear me so
that that's my goal is to be right on
the other side of that particular line
and cats and exactly only animals
there's a whole untapped market in the
podcast arena that I'm really going for
but as long as they can operate the
books at the Nielsen families that's
exactly right so when so Biden I've been
saying for a long time because
he is 100% name ID because he's not
scary
he and part of the fact that he's not
scary is the fact that he doesn't seem
completely functional he just seems like
a default candidate who's there that's
actually a pretty good position to be in
as opposed to somebody like Warren who
Trump can rightly point to somebody like
Warren and say you really want to screw
up this whole country just by electing
somebody who's this who's got these
crazy policy proposals Biden doesn't
seem to know which state he's in and I
actually don't think that cuts
necessarily against Biden I think that
actually cuts against Trump in some ways
you know I know that Biden is a
constitutional expert but he should be
he was actually there in the room when
they wrote the document that's the line
that I just heard be he is he's
qualified and he's capable he's
certainly more experienced than his
running mate Barack Obama was he's been
engaged in foreign policy he knows the
rules of the road and when he gets
righteously indignant he's actually very
effective but that comes less and less
often and I think it's coming across and
I was mean as opposed to moralistic but
I would not dismiss him and frankly as
much as she is extreme in her positions
and some Democrats are now starting to
get nervous about her Elizabeth Warren
is electable all these people are
electable and the president's gonna have
to figure out how he can debate them
without making his own language his own
Twitter account the issue if he can
focus on where the country is right now
he will be reelected if the focus is on
him as a person I got to tell you I
talked to Republicans who will not give
him another chance if that's what
they're voting on so this has been my
going theory is that if the election is
a referendum on the Democratic candidate
the Democrats lose if the referendum is
an elect an election on Trump personally
then Trump loses and I felt the same way
in 2016 I think what everybody got wrong
about 2016 is they thought it was gonna
be a referendum on Trump because he was
this out-of-the-box character and it
actually was a referendum on Hillary
Clinton with a huge number of Democrats
saying number one she's gonna win so I'm
not showing up to vote and I were trying
to like her that much I'm certainly not
getting
up in the middle of the in the middle of
the winter to go vote for this person
out like very much was certainly going
to win and my great fear with Biden as a
Republican is that you're not going to
have that it's not gonna be a referendum
on Biden because how do you have a
referendum on a piece of paper like it's
just he's these days what do you what do
to you he's a boring nothing of a like
he's a man who's run for president
eighty seven times and lost each time
the only reason he's even on the stage
right now is because of his association
with an all-time great politician Barack
Obama and even with the fact that he has
the glow of Obama cast over him he still
can't break 30% a national poll among
Democrats yes but they did not pulled
him down no that's right he's no he's
durable he's very durable
at this point Howard Dean was collapsing
right at this point and muskie was
collapsing I can give you a list of but
Gary Hart who had surged up was already
coming down at this point
uh he is durable and he's credible
he feels like Romney 2012 it feels like
the Democrats saw a guy who was kind of
the default candidate and then they said
well let's take a look at all these
other candidates and then you got the
rotating wheel of candidates just like
in 2012 or suddenly Herman Cain was was
leading for five minutes and then it was
back to the original bags like okay fine
we tried all these other people I guess
we'll settle on him and it feels that
way with with Biden especially because
nobody's been able to crack any amount
of black support except for Biden ones
once he gets to the South do you think
that the primary the primary schedule is
gonna matter here at all I think this is
both Iowa and New Hampshire then he gets
hurt and with Bloomberg coming into the
race and I would say to you Bloomberg
has no chance or had no chance this
Democrats don't like billionaires but
when you're the only one with money and
36 percent of the delegates are up in
one day and everybody has spent
everything that they have and you still
have tens of millions of dollars to
spend you can't write them off I noticed
as I'm traveling I'm at airport
restaurants or I'm in my hotel room I
turn on the TV and there's a there's a
Bloomberg ad everywhere constantly I
know how much this costs this guy is
advertising everywhere and it's going to
have an impact it may not have an impact
in Iowa New Hampshire it may not have an
nationwide but on Super Tuesday states
he's gonna be a player you know the
rules unlike the Republicans where it
was very much winner-take-all so all you
had to do is get 35% in some state in
the democratic rule so if you get 15% in
the congressional district
you get delegates you get 15% statewide
you get delegates so it's very hard you
can be getting 15 or 20% in state after
state and you're still running up a good
percentage of Delegates for the national
convention we could easily have a
situation where it is brokered I was
about to ask you that like what do you
think are the chances of a brokered
convention and if it is brokered what
are the chances they go off the board
for somebody like Michelle Obama and if
they went off the board for her that's
game set and match agreed and again I
would love to take this podcast I'd love
to take this broadcast and show it to
trump and watch him go crazy no one's
done the Michelle Obama Donald Trump
matchup that's not a close match up
that's a 60/40 matchup I agree with that
and I and they'll protect her they'll
shelter her she spent the last eight
years building and rebuilding herself
from the radical who was saying her
husband was gonna heal the soul of the
country and she was writing theses about
how America was systemically racist and
now she's everybody's everybody's in
don't like gee she's reading these nice
books about how about how she raises her
kids and she she's Oprah but politically
savvy you have mayor Pete which haven't
talked about Biden Warren and Sanders
all four of them have a claim to 15
percent of the vote well evolve for them
stay in and there'll be some wild card
then it becomes very hard to get to 50
percent of the vote and super-delegates
do not vote on the first ballot so they
can't tilt it in any direction until the
second ballot yeah this election cycle
the Democrats could go all the way to
June and even into July what do you
think are the chances in a second I ask
you the chances of Hillary Clinton
jumping back in the race because she
obviously is okay well that answers that
question so I'll ask you a different
question in just one second but first
it's holiday season and let me tell you
someone you're not you're not Santa
that means why should you drive around a
vehicle with lots of presents in it
especially to the post office instead
use stamps calm stamps.com brings all
the services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products or
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages every day stamps.com can handle
it all with ease simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 any letter any package and in class
of mail anywhere you want to send it
once your mail is ready just hand it
your mail carrier or drop it in a
mailbox it is indeed that simple with
stamps com he had five cents off every
first class stamp and up to 40% off
Priority Mail stamps com it's a no
brainer it saves you time it saves you
money so if you haven't tried it yet
what exactly are you waiting for don't
delay sign up right now we use it here
at the daily wire offices I use stamps
calm myself do not spend a minute of
your holiday season at the post office
this year sign up for stamps calm
instead there is no risk and with my
promo code Shapiro you get a special
offer it includes a four week trial plus
free postage and the digital scale no
long term commitments or contracts using
our code you'll be saving money and
supporting the show so head on over to
stamps com click on that microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Shapiro
that stamps comm enter Shapiro stands
calm never go to the post office again
okay so let me ask you about people who
to judge because he's the one name who's
not been mentioned yet people seem to be
overlooking him as a national candidate
because he hasn't really had this major
surge in the national polling he's had
some surges in State polling
particularly the early states he has no
play in among black voters obviously
he's good but they don't know him what I
think that's a matter of learner's do
you actually think that it is the the
oft-cited possibility that maybe gay men
are not going to work too well for a lot
of black voters in the south well that's
half of it that is half of it and that's
a conversation that needs to happen in
the black community but he still has not
been introduced to the country like he
has in Iowa New Hampshire they've seen
him I've seen him campaign in my travels
across the country I've seen all these
people do their stump speeches and mayor
Pete is the quietest of them he's the
most unassuming the most humble he stays
as long as he has to stay he has a very
few applause lines and amazing answers
policy answers
calming answers
he brings people together we hear that
phrase who's gonna find common ground
he's the definition of common ground and
I watched people as they walk out and
they're all blown away by him he is
everyone's second choice which means
that that's why he's doing so well right
now in these two states because he's
becoming the first choice he is the
highest ratio of favorable to
unfavorable of any of the candidates and
the more you know him the more you like
him there's very few candidates that
have all three of those going for him so
I think he's got a way to go up even
though they're starting to focus on him
but yeah there is an anti-gay mentality
that still exists within the religious
component of the African American
community and it's something that he
needs to challenge among them and I
don't know how he does it because it's
not who he is
he does not wear it on a sleeve but he
does not hide it either and that's why
of all the early states the one I'm most
interested in is South Carolina because
percentage of black voters biggest
percentage of religious voters Iowa is
not religious its spiritual but not
religious New Hampshire's not religious
at all it's all economic voters Nevada
you know it's Vegas and whatever South
Carolina we're gonna find out what
happens in the black churches and that's
gonna be fascinating so what do you
think are the actual odds you had to
make the odds for the Democrats right
now where did you where'd you place
people and I've been all over there
there was a time when I thought Harris
we all thought Harris at the very
beginning and then turns out that she's
horrible as a candidate just awful when
you nursed just sheared garbage as a
candidate and they're you know they're
blaming sexism they're blaming racism
it's like well the racism things like
Barack Obama never existed like no and I
am amused by watching Cory Booker call
his own Democratic Party base racist if
they don't put him on the stage because
obviously he's the only other black
person in the race and so now the
comment was out he's like I'm so sad
about it but also cut me a check please
cut me a check okay yeah but how about
Biden saying that he was supported by
the only black female in the US Senate
and Harris is up on stage yet that was
very funny I thought it was I just I
black for like five minutes after that
was done I think I have to give the
highest odds to Senator Warren and
here's why she's raising among the most
if not the most second she's got the
best organization second to Bernie third
she's been at this and she's had a
national platform so she's not gonna
have a mistake she may do something
wrong such as being honest about
Medicare for all and how much it's gonna
cost but she wanted that discussion that
wasn't a mistake
to her that's about explaining why the
rich and corporations need to pay more
so she wants that debate and I think the
Democrats want to nominate a woman I
really do I think they want to make up
for what happened with Trump and Clinton
so I give her number one I give Joe
Biden number two even though I think he
loses both Iowa New Hampshire simply
because his national numbers are very
impressive his support within the
African American community is very
strong and then third would be mayor
Pete I don't think Bernie Sanders has
any shot the nomination because
Elizabeth Warren is taking away his
votes and because at some point I'm just
expecting him to do what Jim from tax he
did he just he doesn't remind me of
Larry David he reminds me of Jim from
taxi that he's just gonna be waving his
arms and suddenly it's just gonna drop
Bernie Sanders is so old takes him an
hour and half to watch 60 minutes he's
so old his favorite painting is the Last
Supper if you look carefully he's the
second way to free laughs Bernie Sanders
is so old the only time it doesn't have
to pee is when he's peeing all three of
trumps wives are immigrants all three of
them it's living proof that there are
some jobs only an immigrant will take
equal opportunity okay yes I got one
more okay so I was at the White House
Christmas party it's interesting I
wasn't invited this year but I was there
last gen I finally got the guts to ask
the president what does the J in Donald
J Trump stand for you know he told me
genius
[Laughter]
let's talk about the genius in the
Republican Party right now so the
Republicans have the Senate they had
they had until recently the house they
have the president say they weren't
dominating at the state level and it
seems like all of it is slipping away
and slipping away pretty quickly how
much of that is due to Trump personally
and how much of that is just a crisis of
identity inside the Republican Party it
feels as though the Republican Party is
splitting in a thousand different ways
and that there's no coherent glue
holding it together other than mere
opposition to the left which is a glue
but it can't be the only glue out in
2016 they had more governorships more
senators more congressmen more state
houses more State sentence more mayor's
than they had in 100 years there were
more elected officials who were
identified with the Republican Party
than any time in a century and what did
they do with it
did they reform government no did they
transition and transform and transcend
Washington's control and influence and
send it back to the states none of that
did they offer the country a specific
vision on health care with a policy to
go with it they could have done anything
and the truth is they accomplished some
things but not what would have deserved
them having as much power as they did
and it'll never come again and the
amazing thing and the one that I'm most
angry about is that they could have
shifted power back to the states and
localities they had the votes to do it
in the House and Senate because they had
a whole bunch of Democrats who did not
want Trump making those decisions so
they would have done it
you had California Democrats who would
have voted with Southern Republicans to
take power out of Washington and send it
back to the states where it belongs
and they didn't do any of it and now
they're being punished for it and they
have no one to blame but themselves I do
wonder if some of the big kind of
Republican talking point items are even
doable in in today's America
well speaking specifically here of
entitlement reform for example which was
Paul Ryan's Bugaboo and who's never able
to get anywhere with that how much of
that is be
as Republicans don't know how to talk
about entitlement reform and how much of
that is because people actually just do
not want to hear entitlement reform and
every country that has ever undergone
any sort of entitlement reform has been
forced to it by austerity measures look
but look what's going on right now in
France they are protesting every day in
there shooting tear gas underneath the
Arc de Triomphe in Colombia I got caught
in a protest I okay I walked a few
blocks to get into it and then I realize
I needed to get out of it there were
over 300 thousand people demanding that
they not reform pensions down there all
across the globe this is happening
government's 10 15 20 years ago gave
away way too much now they realize they
can't afford to pay for it they're
trying to right the ship and voters
won't let them and they even know the
damage but they'll say hey I paid for it
I worked for it I earned it you take it
out of someone else's hide not mine and
the Democrats are smart in this
perspective they know that once you give
a voter a gift a program any kind of
benefit they will not let you take it
away no tax is ever temporary and no
program is ever temporary they make them
permanent and I think the GOP did not
understand that and the only time they
could have done it is when they had the
White House the Senate in the house and
they need the governorships as well they
had it all they had everything and I
won't be around that much longer you
have a long time to go you will look
back at the years 2000 17 and 18 as the
greatest loss of opportunity you may
love in your case you don't love him but
she may like Donald Trump you may like
what conservatism means to the country
but I say to you that the opportunity
versus the result will never be greater
than those two years 17 and 18 and
they're not coming back again one of the
great debates inside the Republican
Party and this was taking place before
Trump but it's been exacerbated and
accelerated by Trump is the is the
debate over which direction to move in
the future so after 2012 there was the
famous Republican document
the RNC they came out and said we need
to reach out to new demographic groups
and maybe that means shifting policy on
things life and how's that worked out
for them yeah well that as I was about
to say President Trump came back with it
with a different sort of analysis if you
can call it that but there are certainly
people doing this analysis saying it's
easier to win an additional 5% of the
white vote than it is to win an
additional 15% of the Hispanic vote and
so you double down on what brought you
here and the and the future of the
Republican Party basically lies in
immigration restriction ISM and economic
subsidies and really catering to the
white working-class building up those
numbers so that it's 2 to 1 3 to 1 is
that conservatism I mean not in my
opinion it's not but I but and I'm a
pollster I'm a communications guy so I
have my own point of view and nobody
cares to hear it they want to know who's
gonna win and they want to know how to
win don't really want to know my
philosophy but I do question this my
grandparents immigrants they came in
from Ukraine I was over in Ukraine and
you this is your exclusive I was in
Ukraine why all this stuff was going on
and I had no idea I was there to do some
speeches for the State Department to
talk to students to talk to elected
officials they were telling me that they
were seeking American aid and they
weren't getting it it's fascinating to
me because I was hearing stuff that did
not make sense and then a couple months
later it made sense we're not a house
not to Ukraine we a lot of us consider
Ukraine to be allies is there a house
sound to the Russians why suddenly as
Ukraine the enemy I'm sorry to those
people who say that they tried to
intervene in our election but the
Russians tried to intervene in our
election not the Ukrainians we have to
figure out a way to get along with China
China is an opponent they may be an
enemy they don't compete fairly
they've manipulate their currency they
steal our intellectual property and
Trump is right is right to hold them
accountable but shouldn't we be bringing
Canada with us shouldn't we be getting
Germany and Britain
in the other countries that trade with
them shouldn't we align with France in
Korea so it's all of us trying to move
China why are we trying to do this alone
we see issues with weather right now and
this is the one that they're gonna be
all pissed off over something is
happening and it's not about heat is
about the intensity of these storms and
the consistency of them and
unfortunately the predictability of them
we can't turn a blind eye to it it's not
60/40 or 70/30 among the scientific
community it's 95 to 5 and I say this is
someone who challenged the science of
climate 20 years ago we've learned a lot
in 20 years I don't want the same
equipment they would have operated on my
brain 20 years ago operating on me now
our science gets better our knowledge of
the economy gets better our information
gets better and by the way I thought to
be a conservative meant that you
respected and celebrated the work of the
CIA or the FBI that we respected and
appreciated the efforts of the police
and the first responders in the idea
that we are now trashing our
intelligence services that to me I
didn't know that that's the side that
conservatives are taking to me that was
always on the left
so tell me cuz I don't know what is
conservatism what side are we on what do
we believe because the things that I was
raised from Jim and William Buckley and
tinkerer Patrick and Richard Perle and
Ronald Reagan
some of those things don't seem to be
conservative today and so I don't know
so in a second don't ask whether you
think that's a result of Trump and you
think whether that's a durable
ideological change inside the Republican
Party or do you think that this is just
sort of a temporary Trump was the vessel
he defeated Hillary Clinton and then
once Trump is no longer president then
this actually plays out in real time
when we get to have that that
intellectual fight but first it's the
holiday season that means it's time to
think about your death no no really it's
not but if you don't want to think about
death probably should just get your life
insurance now then you don't have to
think about death anymore
if life insurance is one of the things
weigh down on your holiday list policy
genius might be able to help you cross
it off they will find you the right life
insurance at the best price and do all
the work you need to help you get
covered policy genius makes finding the
right life insurance a breeze in minutes
you can compare quotes from the top
insurers and find the best price you
could say fifteen hundred bucks or more
a year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies once you apply
the policy genius team handles all the
paperwork and the red tape and policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy it can also help you find the right
home and auto insurance disability
insurance so if you need life insurance
you're not sure where to start though
why not start at policy genius com it
only takes a few minutes to find the
right life insurance policy apply cross
another thing off that Christmas to-do
list policy genius when it comes to life
insurance it's nice to get it right and
it's kind of important because if your
plots before you get it you're in
serious trouble go check out policy
genius right now policy genius.com go
check them out so before we go on what
is the answer is it that we're going to
have different definitions of
conservatism and we're going to fight it
is conservatism pro or anti immigrant or
should we not be having this argument
don't conservatives care about the
environment if we are supporters of
tradition and legacy don't we want to
ensure that the air that we breathe and
the water that we drink is safe for
generation because we believe in delayed
gratification isn't conservatism about
border security and alliances with NATO
and in North America isn't Canada one of
our strongest allies should we be
fighting with the Canadian
Prime Minister tell me you're smart guy
you tell me what is conservatism today I
mean I think that conservatism today is
anti leftism and that is not enough and
this is a case I've been making
consistently for years is that there was
a very famous talk-show host of whom I
was dropped as a fan who in 2016 shifted
his definition of conservatism he had
the advanced can the advanced Institute
of the Institute of Advanced
conservative Studies so what he called
the rush called at this and then in 2016
he shifted it to the Institute of
Advanced anti left studies and I thought
that that was very telling move because
basically what it suggested is that the
radicalism of the left was to be opposed
and that the political correctness of
the left was to be opposed and that was
pretty much what tied us together there
were no centralized values and this but
that bridge insurance ISM is I thought
was meant to pull you in this was the
Jim and Bill Buckley philosophy which is
to show you okay it does show you the
insanity of the left but it's the pull
you in intellectually to the ideas of
the right I mean I totally know James Q
Wilson I totally agree at this the
conservatism was the smart people the
best educated people the people yes who
do go to Ivy League's but I think they
and this is really a question for you
why did conservatives stop making the
moral case because I think that's really
where this broke down I think that there
was a point in my life where the case
was made that markets were not moral
that you had to add on top of that the
very idea of compassionate compassionate
conservatism was was a good pitch but I
remember having problems with when I was
16 years old because I thought to myself
I don't know why we are being redundant
because the idea there is obviously that
without the modifier conservatism is not
compassionate but my philosophy was
always that that was an oxymoron that
that was a contradiction that
conservatism was about making tough
choices and that the left was about
making everything easy you got a problem
throw money at it you're suffering
here's a check you lost your house we're
gonna take care of it and to the point
where we couldn't afford it but it was
the gift liberalism was about a gift
and conservatism was about personal
responsibility so you're gonna be a
common-sense conservative but you
couldn't be a compassionate conservative
that they actually got to Title II agree
that I mean and I think that my main
objection to the the idea was that you
that common sense is not compassionate I
mean the idea of conservatism is that
when you make those tough decisions you
are doing something good for people and
that when you cut people a check very
often you're doing something bad for
people what you're actually doing is
enervating them and making them unable
to support themselves and making them
dependent and so by pitching
conservatism as well it'll be
conservatism but it'll be nice socome
well you just took the heart right out
of what it is you're talking about and
you're setting up an expectation that
without the big government spending
programs conservatism is actually just
mean and petty and cruel so there's this
idea that's been built up in the
conservative movement you see it
manifests right now that conservatism is
about heartless markets and you see
conservatives say the sort of stuff it's
about heartless markets free markets
that are nasty to people and so we have
to curb their application because we
have to chain the markets up and make
them work for us though the markets are
not an actual here the reflection of the
the markets are a reflection of a basic
individual right to alienate your own
labor they are inherently moral and the
idea that a market is not moral that you
have to that you have to curb the market
chained it up make it work for the
people no that's that socialist language
that is a language of class it's not the
language of conservatives and we just
described the language of Elizabeth
Warren and Bernice and greed but markets
on their own are not necessarily
compassionate that we are making a
decision as a society which I believe
and this is my own politics has changed
that there are times when markets don't
function correctly that the free market
is not always free and does not always
choose the right thing and that there
can be perversions that cause real
damage and that the best form of an
ideology is one that admits those cases
where it is wrong and always seeks to
improve it I think it's one of the great
things about Western religion is that it
goes through a reformation constantly as
it reexamined its principles its morals
its values acknowledges where it got it
wrong and then seeks to fix it not
through wholesale changes
that's progressivism but through
tinkering at the edges to correct those
things that went wrong there's nothing
wrong with that my issue is twofold one
who believes that markets are evil and
those who believe that markets should
not be touched we have become so
polarized right now I'm scared to death
of the Wall Street Journal because I
know that there's income inequality I
can admit it
there are rich people and there were
poor people and it is not the fault of
every poor person or even a majority of
them that they are poor they've been
denied a decent education they were
denied a decent family they were denied
the same opportunities that we got you
got him and I got him
we were put on the right path we are
responsible for our success or failure
but we at least got on the right path
what about the twenty or twenty five
percent who don't have that opportunity
we get stuck in schools that suck who
are taught by teachers you don't want to
be there that want to get out of class
as soon as they can are taught by
teachers who have trouble with it with
the lesson plan itself and they
shouldn't be there it is not their fault
that they have one parent or no parents
it is not their fault that everything
around them teaches them about bad
behavior you can tell someone to pull
them some up themselves up by their
bootstraps if they don't own boots and
over the last three or four years I'm
working with kids who are teaching me
that they call they they joke that
they're my life coach but they are
teaching me about the twenty percent
that I did not see and every time I sit
with them I hear about another pathology
another horrible story of what they went
through and it isn't their fault and
markets won't help them we have to
intervene but if we destroy economic
freedom in this country we destroy all
the greatness of the last two hundred
thirty years we can help so many more
people individually personally I don't
want the government raising my taxes I'm
in the top 1% and every year I give more
and more every year my percentage goes
higher and higher and I'm giving my time
not just my checks don't government
stop me from doing that get out of my
way and let me make a difference but I
know I have the responsibility to do it
and I know you do too I know on this we
agree that's my frustration there's no
one who speaks for me well I mean I
wonder if again it's the it's the
language of a certain materials point of
view toward government that seems to
have taken over the what I mean by that
is that the original bargain of the
founders was that we would have an
extremely limited government that was
not capable of doing a great many things
in order to protect our rights and that
a government too powerful would have the
ability to invade those but that was
balanced by a feeling of duty that we
had for one another and revelation and
represent representation this is not a
democracy right and our people aren't
even taught that in the government
classes the only direct democracy we
have is in New Hampshire and the other
40 united states
it's a representative it's a republic
and we have to hope that the people
represent us well the problem is they've
now discovered that the more they give
away the more they get elected and that
they forget that half the equation is
spending but the other half is taxation
and it is one of the things I'm angriest
about about this administration why do
we have a deficit and a debt that's out
of control why are we on the wrong side
of the ledger as much as Barack Obama
horse on a yearly basis more during and
and we have the strongest economy now
and he had the weakest economy back then
what has happened to personal
responsibility to agency responsibility
to government responsibility you don't
spend what you don't have and we are
just trying to buy people off the left
and the right that's not conservative
well no this is this is I think but what
I'm arguing about with regard to
materialism and I think that the both
the right on the left believe that the
solution is going to come through some
form of government intervention ISM now
and it seems like that's I mean the
Republicans are spending as much as the
Democrats are more and the Republicans
are not looking to cut programs in any
real way they're looking to maybe trim
around the edges but they're not looking
to restore the value of a social fabric
and absence of government instead what
you hear conversations about are the
failures of capitalism but you never
actually hear about the morality of
capita
for the sphere in which it operates it's
not meant to it's not don't call
capitalism capitalism to too many
Americans is Wall Street and
profitability rather than Main Street in
small business and opportunity I've
actually told conservatives stop using
the phrase capitalism because it
undermines your philosophy rush limbaugh
came at me by name saying that I'm a
sellout and I say to him because I know
he watches you I say to him if you
defend capitalism you're defending the
parts of the economy that the American
people resent and they want to vote out
of office but if you defend economic
freedom those are the principles of the
founding fathers those are the
principles that have held this country
so strong for so many decades and it all
actually goes back to one issue which we
haven't talked about it's not been
brought up in the Democratic debates no
one ever talks about it because we say
it's a local issue and it is at the core
it's at the root of everything that is
going wrong and that is the sorry state
of our public schools
if we can't educate and I've got my
staffer here who insists on using 22
words when 16 will do why does he write
so much because he was told I need a
seven hundred word essay not valuing
each word but just trying to get as many
words onto a page we have schools that
allow kids to graduate with diplomas
they cannot read that they actually
discourage those who are smartest and
they bring them down to the average so
that no one can excel i I think we are
destroying the fabric of this country by
allowing our schools to be destroyed and
it's not that I'm anti public school I
want all of our schools to do well but I
don't care whether it's public or
private I don't care whether it's merit
pay performance pay or what you call it
show me another occupation where we pay
the best people know better than where
we pay the worst show me something more
important that we value more than our TV
sets in our cars if our car doesn't work
we'll go to the shop
and if they don't fix it the first time
we'll yell at them our kids are coming
out more damaged than our televisions in
our cars and we let it happen that
parents aren't involved in the lives of
their kids because they don't have time
or they don't know what they're being
taught and that we have principals who
cannot ensure that their schools are a
safe learning environment it is a
disaster it is a tragedy and I am
begging these Democratic candidates to
talk about it and nothing has happened
well the minute people who judge talking
about he got racked over the coals we
just got destroyed because there's that
old audio of him from 2011 talking about
pathologies in particular communities in
which and he was even blaming the kids
or even the parents who's saying people
are put in circumstances where they they
don't have role models who value
education they've never seen anybody
work the system and succeed that way and
so why would they buy into it and he got
just destroyed for saying something that
was basically true basically it is true
it is accurate and someone needs to look
at the cameras trained the eye and say
if you allow this to happen anymore over
the next 10 years then it is your fault
when when our kids are speaking Chinese
it is your fault when the Chinese
companies are coming in with better
technology better manufacturing and
better capability to out-compete our
kids I'm gonna tell you something I
teaching my you Abu Dhabi it's my
greatest thrill of my life I would give
up politics I would give up my corporate
work I care about nothing more than I
care about teaching and then why you Abu
Dhabi is the most global education in
the world the highest percentage of any
student or Emiratis themselves at 14%
and Americans are at 12% there's no
place will you get this mix over a
hundred countries are represented in the
1200 students my Chinese students I'm
gonna it's I'm gonna get yelled at for
this to my Chinese students want to know
how to get an A my Chinese students are
lobbying to keep the library open 24
hours a day
my Chinese students are trying to figure
out what they need to know what they
need to learn how they will succeed and
my American students are looking for the
bar they're looking to have a drink in
they're looking to have fun there there
was a strawberry that was taken of
Chinese Mother's and American mothers
what they prioritize for their kids
American moms one of the kids to be
happy Chinese kids wanted their children
to be educated well the Chinese kids got
what they wanted parents got what they
wanted their kids educated and they're
really unhappy the American kids are
really happy and really uneducated and
if we don't get our act together then
this country will not survive the
yelling and screaming about Donald Trump
or Nancy Pelosi or impeachment that is
all irrelevant if we have a healthy
school a healthy classroom we can
survive anything because we will be we
will produce students we're able to
handle the problems of the 21st century
but if we continue to allow our schools
to deteriorate if we continue to fight
over charter we fight over the teachers
unions the education is not an
Employment Program if Teach for America
works let those teachers in there the
unions are fighting to get Teach for
America thrown out you know why because
those young people teach better then the
teachers who are 25 years older than
them because they care and they want to
spend time with their students we need
institutions like NYU Abu Dhabi who are
teaching a global population global
issues global concerns global threats
we're gonna solve them in America and
we're gonna do good things for the world
but if our kids can't compete for the
kids from China Japan and Korea and the
other European nations if we continue to
score xx in language and and xxx and
math God knows what we score in science
and we're heading down we really are so
in a second I wanna ask you about go
back to the topic we addressed very
briefly originally and that is is it
possible to sell anybody anything
basically can you sell it can you sell
ice to an Eskimo using the language of
the correct language of politics but
first you may not know this I'm a watch
guy and here is a watch that I truly
love look at this this is a venture
watch it's magnificent all venture
watches are
crafted with top-quality materials
including surgical grade stainless steel
real top grain Italian leather and the
back of the watches includes a piece of
genuine is Halligan marble these are
materials you wouldn't expect in a watch
at such an affordable price because
here's the thing the price point is
really really good with the holidays
coming up so fast you need to head over
to VIN Cheryl watches comm /a Pierrot
and you can see my favorite picks and
use code Shapiro at check out for 15%
off your entire order plus they're
covering shipping cost so I have this
engraved watch one of the things they do
is they'll engrave the back of your
watch those facts don't care about your
feelings
I know these timepieces make an
incredible gift it is the perfect time
to pick up a timepiece for that
significant other in fact I've done this
with my wife half my family have in
Cheryl watches at this point with
multiple collections for both men and
women you're bound to find a design that
matches their look and style perfectly
they will thank you then Cheryl believes
watches can do more than tell time they
tell the world what you're all about
they make a statement about who you are
it immediately establishes you as
ambitious smart successful without you
needing to shout it or you can lie about
being all of those things by wearing of
in Cheryl watch people just get it when
they see wearing one of their watches
the deal is fantastic go to VI n CER o
watches comm /up here that's been Cheryl
watches comm /up arrow and use code
shapiro to get 15% off okay so let's
talk about the use of language and
politics which of course is your
specialty I think people get
uncomfortable when we talk about the use
of language in politics because and this
is sort of I think what Trump may be
getting at when he says I don't even
care I'm just gonna say what I feel and
that's my appeal do people feel I I
certainly can see it people feel like if
the question here is just about using
the right words do the ideas even matter
well are any ideas sellable in America
so long as you use the right words no it
has to be credible it has to be
authentic people have to feel that you
should not be taxed just because you die
that a death tax is not fair to to a
family that is going through a great
tragedy and they have to get their
assets in order and they have to figure
out what thing I have to write to their
government we think that a parents are
going to sacrifice their kids should be
able to enjoy that sacrifice it does
matter if it's a scholarship or a
voucher about use a piece of paper
an opportunity scholarship is a chance
for a better future even something so
simple we've got water here
sparkling water if this is carbonated it
means it got chemicals but if this is
sparkling it's a refreshing taste so
yeah the words do matter I was
criticized for Obamacare because of
mines research we called it a government
takeover now that people criticize me
backed away three years later because
people really did lose the doctor they
really did lose the hospital they did
lose their health care plan it actually
was government involvement in health
care so his politifact famously calling
it the lie of the year was yesterday and
then it took three years for them to
back away from it because we saw that
what the Republicans had said about it
turned out to be true that said
messaging does matter how you
communicate it does matter Paul Ryan had
the most complicated convoluted defense
of his health care plan and we were able
to summarize it in 14 words the choice
in control you want the affordability
you need and the quality you deserve
simple and that's what the plan did but
he talked about competition and selling
health plans across state lines
it was just unintelligible for most
people so yes language matters but you
cannot sell ice to Eskimos and it is not
manipulation you actually have a
responsibility to clarify what you mean
you have a responsibility to say what
you mean and mean what you say and
that's what I try to help I really
stopped doing it I'm not really involved
in much policy anymore and I'm not
involved in any campaigns because they
don't like it it's 97 percent negative
and I don't want to do it and I realized
this ten years ago but it does frustrate
me and I cannot look at a political ad
without oh now that woman over there
should be twenty years older the kid
that just came in too young we need
someone slightly older
where's the line my biggest Bugaboo of
our political ads is that they love to
film them in kitchens because kitchen
table economics are balancing your books
at the kitchen the truth is most people
don't use the kitchen table for it they
do it in their den second is that all
the kitchens I see in these ads have
islands most of your viewers do you have
an island in your we do okay well then
your your your well off I can tell your
your jacket yes yes its listeners yeah
so you're doing markets economic freedom
economic freedom that freedom is its
economic freedom the kitchens are way
upper middle-class kitchens and they
aren't most kitchens aren't like that so
I still see things and it's not just the
words it's the visuals that they use and
sometimes they get frustrated but
messaging does matter so tell me about
the focus group method because been much
criticized and much praised what what
exactly is it and why does it work you
learn from people by asking them
questions which is what you do here I
wonder what percentage of your guests
ask you questions back again because
that's what this is about is asking the
viewer what you think what you know what
you believe what you're afraid of what
you want the most how can I inspire you
to do more give more be more involved in
helping others
it is awesome because it allows you to
explain in your words not mine
what matters most it's why I learned
about the word imagine most powerful
word in the English language when you
ask people to imagine a better America
you would say what one where I'm afraid
to do it I want with my life and not be
bothered my children so I won't he won't
be able to hear him off microphone but
I'm asking you camera guy if you're to
imagine a better America what do you
think of or what do you see and I'll
repeat it
so he says unifying but he does
something which is even more important
he does this brings his hands together
that's showing that not only is he
thinking it but he's actually feeling it
and one more what do you think more
opportunity for what for industry Wow
a pro-corporate list over there well he
knows where he's working there are there
are say 10 people in this set every one
of them has a different definition of it
but everyone is correct that's what a
focus group does it explains this it
allows us allowed me to understand the
importance of efficient effective
accountable government not small
government not limited government but a
government is more for Less government
that only does what it does well and the
government that's held responsible if it
doesn't deliver that's efficient
effective and accountable something
that's meaningful and measurable they
taught me that through focus groups so
much of my language comes from asking
questions and listening to the responses
rather than just putting it out on a
very dry survey where you have five or
seven or nine different choices focus
group allows you to go wherever you want
to go and it also shows me intensity and
passion and that's what's frightening to
me right now when I used to moderate
these people would be expressive but
they knew when to stop the groups I've
done over the last three or four years
the one I did for CBS News two nights
before the election in 2016 if you go
back to the video because they kept it
in I walked off the set again I'll give
you something I never told anyone I quit
that night we were two days before the
election I was livid at these people
because they were just shouting at each
other yelling at each other you could
barely hear it in fact the sound guys
said at one moment it went into the red
it actually was distorted and you hear
it happen and I'm telling them stop and
they won't stop and I just
and then told the executive producer at
the time I quit this is what you all
have created this is what Clinton and
Trump and the media have created in the
American psyche you go live with it I'm
going to New Zealand and he said to me I
can't use bad language but he said to me
get the hell back in there stop
complaining and do your job
we put a lot of money to put these
cameras here do your damn job get in
there
and I thought to myself wow you're a
really mean guy he's my boss so I have
to do it and they went back in and
finished it but they kept it in the tape
so in one second I wanna ask you
something more fun and that is you're
apparently a I've been told by many
people you have a very nice house and
you have an enormous amount of
historical memorabilia so and I asked
about your favorite piece of American
memorabilia you have is but first if you
want to hear Frank once is the answer
you have to be a daily water subscriber
if you want to subscribe head on over to
daily we're calm click on that subscribe
button you can hear the end of our
conversation over there Franklin thank
you so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it Franklin's political
commentator pollster check him out his
got a bunch of York Times best-selling
books as well Frank really appreciate
your time thank you
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy borin associate producer Colton
Haas
our guests are booked by Kaitlyn Maynard
post-production is supervised by Alex
Singaram editing by Donovan Fowler audio
is mixed by Mike Camino hair and makeup
is by Joshua alvera title graphics by
Cynthia Angulo the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19